if you're east asian chinese taiwanese
korean
you have in my opinion more advantages
than someone who's filipino like my
friend who is filipino told me oh we're
the black people of asians yeah
that's why they love basketball
man they love basketball i don't i think
they love basketball more than black
people
i respect them absolutely i respect them
you know i mean there's just something
really cool about
like someone just trying regardless you
know it's kind of like um
david and goliath except everyone's just
david
it's a lot of it's like a five on five
david's let's go at each other
you wanna shoot from david
shout out to the filipinos yeah i mean
basketball is a great sport take
properly
filipinos i
care about being accepted by white
america
being accepted in white culture um
means i guess i'm not like discriminated
in a heavy way and i think there is a
level of comfort that i take in that
um not that that doesn't mean i'm like
going against like any other culture
but it there is a comfort level and i
think it's a privilege that i have that
i'm able to be looked that way
even though i'm a minority yeah i think
it's a sad reality that i have to
sit here literally only because i think
currently white america runs our society
i mean if you want to work in any kind
of professional settings i think there
is some
element of care that you have to have
for this well yeah
definitely i cannot be here and be like
you know i don't care yeah that's that's
a lie
that's a blatant lie if you code switch
you care to some degree
not because if you want to be accepted
it's either you want to be accepted
because you know
not because you want to please them or
whatever what not but
it's for your livelihood you want to
have a job you want to be able to
so yeah if you close with you care code
switching is just
changing the way that you talk
accordingly according to
the environment and who in the situation
so if you don't speak the same way
to your friends and you speak at work
you're co-switching that's it
is that being accepted by white society
or is that just being accepted by a
professional environment
i think they're even in a black country
i think one goes with
the other the standard is based on
and and it was created by i guess you
could say it was
created by but if i live in a black
society there's still
a certain behavior that i have to show
at work that i can't show my day to day
definitely
of course i'm talking about an american
setting if you are cold switching and
you are
live in for example if you are in a
place where it's
predominantly black people your code
switching
is not for the same reason you're going
to be go switching but it's not
necessarily for this for the same reason
but if we're talking if we're talking
about we're talking about why in america
right there and then
um i think yeah it could be a little bit
of both and in order for me to
benefit myself my family
i need to align with that sometimes it
actually gives me
great anxiety when i step into a
situation
and i know i'm the only poc because
then suddenly i am
why more and more i have a problem with
the word poc
you were fine with black men they just
gave you something else i was i just got
acquainted with black men it's kind of
like when they gave you cisgendered
heteronormative uh cis hat
yeah they tried to slurp remember
remember
yeah they tried to slur me with the set
and i'm like
okay now you go just go event words but
it's okay but it doesn't affect me that
way but it's okay but i'm a poc like
they don't want to say
person of color and colored you can't
say color because that's bad
but person of color that's good next
generation is going to pop
out and then they're going to have a
problem with person of color
a lot of the times when i'm in a group
setting when everybody's asian
especially asian people who only have
asian friends 100
i know exactly i get this weird feeling
that now you're going to label me as the
white one
and i hate that because i'm not white
it's just a really weird identity crisis
which you described was pretty much
your experience my high school i was
the guy that was ah he's not black
enough i've been said that
some of the people we know they like you
know
prototype he was like yo yeah don't
don't then people they thought you were
white white
they thought yeah it was like nah man he
chilled your cool dude and everything
and stuff but you were just adapting
pretty much but they saw you were
adapting too much exactly so
i was white i was white to them would
you say that you
don't want to disappoint your people
okay trying to quote the documentary i'm
mad at you though
one document are you talking about eric
the documentary that we released last
week that you can view on youtube
for free that you should probably click
a link to because it's going to be the
pinned comment
down there that one i'll just click
you're never going to be and it i
understand but you're never going to be
accepted
that's how they've set this country up
and like as a black woman
i gave up on that a long time ago
because i know i'll never be accepted
oddly enough a lot of
practices rooted within the black
community come from the
desire to be accepted by the dominant
society and their beauty standards
perming hair doing all this stuff you
know
a lot of that's ingrained from like
generational messaging and imagery
that we've internalized in there for
when we want to be accepted or we want
to see
seen as professional we cater to these
fashion looks
so i think it's interesting that you
think why would you say that like for
most black people this
is not a reality if you live in this
context in this north american context
you do certain things to be accepted
whether you we're realizing it or not
most people are i can speak to this from
like an immigrant standpoint
but like i find when immigrants come
here oftentimes at least from my country
specifically
like we're always taught to like be
quiet or to make ourselves smaller as to
not draw attention to ourselves
so that we don't like make the locals
if you will uncomfortable that's like
something my parents
immuted me since i was young and so even
when i grew up old like i felt
uncomfortable raising my voice in public
or around anybody because i thought i
was being a nuisance but that's just
that messaging and that programming of
like wanting to be accepted
and to not cause problems so i think
it's all ingrained into us
in ways we don't even sometimes realize
i grew up in a conservative white uh
area it was such a big difference where
i was like you know what
i'm going to be the blackest person ever
so for me it was one of those things of
anti i had to learn how to be more
respectful to their culture
because i felt like they were traveling
on mine so much i went the opposite
almost militant black
[Laughter]
msg's kind of lit though you know you
know um
i think asian people are cool personally
right like i'll try to like
hang with them or because i love
learning culture so i'll try to like go
and have conversations or whatever and
sometimes it's just
been like this more like standoffish
like this is our group
and you know we have our own like little
thing going on and so i feel like for me
i was like what
like what's up with that right i grew up
in a predominantly east asian
neighborhood arcadia
in san gabriel valley but there's still
this group of like
old white families there they would say
things
and i would back in middle school like i
would kind of repeat it
not really understanding like oh asians
are bad drivers
i'd be like yeah asians are bad drivers
and then i'm like no that's
really what i feel comfortable about
somebody saying something like that
about black people like no i wouldn't so
i kind of had to like correct myself
so what you're saying is that black
people can be
interesting no no no they can be
prejudiced
yes that was prejudice uh you guys uh
live in canada
well she lives in america she feels
similarly so you're gonna have to deal
with the argument at some point uh
get with it my parents didn't hang out
with anybody else
than themselves because it's that
immigrant mentality you kind of stick
with each other
to bring each other up because you feel
as if you're other
you want to succeed in america so
if you've got a friend who is a mechanic
you need your car fixed
you're going to go to that guy because
you speak the same language and so
you're
around the same kind of people actually
growing up
i thought my brother was black
because he had a lot of black friends
all i saw was his black friends is
all he hung out with so i would go to
school and say
hey i have a black brother you know i
thought she was about to say so i would
go to school and i'd be like
hey [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i think some of my assumptions about
asian americans are that they
aren't necessarily fond of black people
or if they're not they don't have any
feeling one way or the other
they just prefer to um be with their own
not that i felt them because that's how
a lot of different races are
i'm going to be honest with you that's
uh that's most immigrants
not very fond of black people that's
everywhere wanna stick with their own
yeah that's every that's everybody
latinos are the same
right if you go to asia yep
they do and you know what even a lot of
young asian people say like they know
their parents are that way
but it's like how are you gonna tell
someone who's lived through world war ii
or who's like been through 50 years of
life they need to change like it's very
difficult to have people change that
kind of mentality even my family
yeah there's comments like that yeah i
see how your mom looked at me when i
stepped in
no not haitians no no no she got she got
she got she's got a different group so
everyone got their group nah not that
one not them people
you know i realize it's very tribalistic
in that sense so i don't know if this is
necessarily like a
to what she was saying regards like she
feels like asians don't it's like
most groups like that brown folks like
it's pretty common
uh for all cultures i tell your mom
actually look at me
hi mom this is eric your friend no he's
not my friend
good just kidding
she didn't even talk to me yeah that was
true she didn't she was cooking
i met her she made you food yo that's
what really matters
that food was delicious that's it that's
it abc
who's eating at least you got here
we're trying to talk eat the food now
you know how i feel about you exactly
does it taste good
you think my mom told me she loved me as
a kid no she just gave me a good lunch
she made you give me your food yo listen
it's like it's like when they beat you
they beat you and that's how they say
sorry you to eat
listen if i went to school my banana
wasn't black i'm like mom loves me today
you know what i'm saying that's what it
is
um i think it's true for me but it's
it's i think
i'm a special case getting the fact of
the industry i work in i work in the
tech industry
i face a lot of just rude comments
ignorant comments
and just um unnecessary things that are
said to me by asian people
i've had um a few asian
co-workers that uh told me that the way
that i talk is inappropriate
that my tone and my voice is
inappropriate for the workplace and i
need to change that and i get that more
from my asian co-workers and asian
managers
than i do my white co-workers so the
only reason why i didn't come up and
agree
is because i have experienced a lot of
information just because i lived in an
asian neighborhood but i really think
that's it i've lived in a white
neighborhood predominantly white
neighborhood i've lived in a
predominantly east asian neighborhood
and personally
i prefer living in a predominantly east
asia neighborhood because in my
experience they leave us alone the
amount of time i've walked through my
my neighborhood and there's an old asian
man like walking towards me
and i nod my head the old asian man just
stares that mean that looks away without
none but
you want to talk about non-confrontation
they are
they don't even acknowledge your
existence at times i mean are you gonna
face
more racism for white people i mean
probably there's just more white people
to potentially face it from
you know it's just a matter of like the
environment that you're in the same way
the girl
who'd faced more racism for asian people
when she lived in the asian neighborhood
well
if you live in a white country you're
most likely going to face more white
racism right like
that's kind of a natural i don't think
it's anything endemic of necessarily
white people per se
because trust me if you go live in other
foreign countries where there's
like a land country or an asian country
like you may face a lot of that
even more being in those environments
and you wouldn't like north america per
se
it's uh hard for me to hear these things
because as somebody who's also
working you know i've worked at a tech
company before and i'm always a manager
in position
and to have somebody talk to someone
like that
i i don't think our community as a whole
this is not the representation
i don't think they would give the same
respect that you guys are giving
and um it's not right
it's it's not right the fact that you
can do that
and give us the benefit down is
so kind it's um i don't think we deserve
it
and um yeah i overall think that
asian communities are very racist when
you see [ __ ] like that
and there's nothing you could do about
it right like you probably see
his parents his grandparents comments
and there's some
like you can't fight everybody at at
some point you can't be like argued at
everybody at
every dinner table you know you can but
i mean you're just not gonna get invited
at the cookout
at some point but but that's the thing
you see it around yourself you see
seeing around you
and you try to do better and then you
know there's other people that remind
you that no
it is happening on both sides you know
they came into a country that wasn't
theirs and then you're facing
them that makes me think of haiti when
the uh the syrians
that went there and and when they first
arrived they faced racism from the black
people when the syrians worked and they
worked and they worked and they had all
the companies
the the the textile companies and stuff
like that and they had the power
they turned around and then they're
doing the same thing to the people you
know i mean so so it's like i see
i see i see haiti when i hear stuff like
that i think it just speaks to the
tribalistic nature of human beings
they just look at other tribes and they
just find reasons to dislike them
because it's just easier to
minimize somebody or to reduce them than
to accept the nuance
of like another group and when you live
as a second generation immigrant where
you're born in the country but your
parents are from somewhere else
well you go to school with people from
all different cultures so you
know that it goes a little bit deeper
than that but then you hear your parents
make such blanket statements
and you're like i love these people but
these people say such hateful things
yet i still love them and they're still
my parents and my family so like how do
you
reconcile those two things that becomes
a difficult conversation
because odds are you're not going to
change their minds so what am i supposed
to stop talking to my parents
because they don't you know i've dated
girls wonderful human beings
their parents thought they would rather
like their daughters
self-delete than they'd be that's a
crazy thing to
does it bother me not anymore because
i've just accepted the way the world is
this is what it is like when if i'm
dating a girl and
she's from a different cu not even just
different race but she's like from a
different
like african like you know tell your
parents where i'm from
because i'm trying to deal with no
nonsense i don't i'm already ready right
so
i've come to accept that and i
understand why it would be difficult for
someone
to hear what people like their parents
might be saying to the people across
from him that's the thing that's just i
think
is going to get better with time
but i don't know what that future looks
like either i don't know what it's going
to look like when our parents generation
is gone
and then we're here i don't see us
having the same kind of mindset that
they had
but i also don't know if that's
necessarily a much better future
i i think we're going to have the same
mindset but for different things
history repeats itself you're going to
be depth if
but not so gifted not only racist
against just
there are a lot of energism there's a
lot of southeast
the south and east erase them thus
prevalent there's
clear black white there's racism a lot
asian americans are more advantaged than
black americans
all right can we skip this portion why i
just get so bored of this kind of
conversation because it's like
how do you quantify a group's
advantages and disadvantages yeah what
are you looking at it is
how are you tabulating this it's a very
subjective it's not something that you
can concretely say
accurately so for me whenever i hear
this it's just like well i feel like
this and i feel like that and
were you guys more fast and i'm just
like ugh what it feels like is like
everyone's fighting for the crumbs
when there's a giant piece of loaf of
bread on the on the plate yeah
do you know what i mean i was about to
say it turns it turns into a misery
competition
yeah that's what i don't like but i'm
also open to
you know maybe there's i'm gonna learn
something differently you know maybe i'm
going to learn something different
or people are going to bring up
something i understand the equivalency
of
this question because it's more than
that
i don't know i've repeated this so many
times but i'm just like breath
the end of the day the biggest
difference you're going to see between
people is going to be finance that's it
you're a rich black person you're
evading taxes all of a sudden you know
what i'm saying
you you're a rich asian person like you
don't see eye to eye with really poor
asian people it's just a different lived
experience
and i think if you talk about what's
affecting you
what's really you know putting laws in
place it's not the
local ku klux klan member across the
street it's going to be the rich people
who are protecting their own interests
and making sure you're getting shafted
so
whenever i hear this discussion i'm like
you guys are fighting over the crumbs
and to me just seems kind of pointless i
kind of think
asian american privilege is white
privilege i think a lot of my
success and opportunities that i got was
purely because of how people judge my
skin color and ethnicity
they thought i was smart they thought i
spoke eloquently
they thought i fit a minority profile
into their culture whatever it may be
but i've never had a negative stereotype
which means i have an
inherent advantage which is the whole
principle of white privilege right so
i think i'd be very disingenuous in
saying that i didn't get a lot of my
successes
or opportunities just because i'm asian
i mean there's plenty of negative
stereotypes
do they affect you as negatively in the
workplace
depends on what workplace but for the
most part in terms of professional
backgrounds yeah i would agree that
you're probably advantaged in that
regards in terms of how you're perceived
uh what are your thoughts about the
relationship between uh black folks and
asians in the west here it's it's weird
it's super weird
it's a spectrum it's either they down
with us and we roll
and we together and everything and stuff
and all about about it
or they don't at all like
there's some spheres where yeah
really yeah outside of dance outside of
dance
outside of dance if what time if i talk
about in the music industry
here uh the dj's either they're with us
or they just do their own thing on their
side but you still talking about people
in the art sphere if you're in the art
sphere
i feel like the arts is a different
thing yeah it to me like i wouldn't even
count that the hearts bring people
together yeah
to me is a different thing i wouldn't
even count that but if you're talking
about like what the experience like yeah
it's like people are tribalistic they
stay with their groups
south asians stay with themselves the
east asians you know do the same thing
and
it's something i've come to accept but i
think you guys can coexist peacefully
sure i think there's a lot of animosity
between the groups it's also tough when
you're poor
and you live across other minorities who
are poor and you inflict harm on those
around you within your communities
who may be asian or black you know it
kind of fuels those like cycles of
resentment because at the end of the day
you know
crime is a matter of proximity so when
you go rob a corner store
it's going to be the asian guy because
the asian guy built this corner store in
the hood you're going to you know what
i'm saying
you're going to rob the store in the
corner right proximity
in that same token when you make those
kind of comments or anything like that
it's going to be people who are near you
so
i don't have any kind of easy solutions
to all this or
you know really great talking points for
me it's i've just kind of accepted the
way the relationship functions
i've learned to accept that there's
going to be a barrier and
it's a self-imposed one at the end of
the day yeah i mean yeah
it is is it like that for every group
yeah never groups like that
a lot of people who do the arts identify
more with the arts at some point than
they do with their own cultural heritage
so that's why it's a different thing
true yeah you're right it's crazy to go
to
to russia and have people twerk there
yeah and they identify with twerking
but they have hella predator bridges
this against black people
i think the other day people especially
when you live in a country where you
don't feel like you're part of the
majority
you're going to kick it you're going to
at some point start to spend time with
people who either look
look like you speak the same language or
have some of the same like cultural
upbringings
just you feel more at ease and i think
as a result of that maybe that's just
this is just the reality of
multiculturalism
when you bring all these old cultures
together on the same plot of land
and you say all right guys figure it out
make your teams
well they're like well i came here with
the chinese people so
and then all the davids get together and
they're like yo philippines let's go
right it's just you call them david
yes stupid
but it's true i just think these kinds
of cycles are kind of inevitable yeah i
don't mean to be like negative or
anything like that i just think it's
going to be that way but i don't think
it has to be as hostile
me personally yeah that's the thing
getting together is one thing the
hostility
is another thing i guess we have nothing
else insightful to say so uh
leave your comments below let us know
what you guys think
[Music]
foreign